hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on native ms and
imms analyses of large proteins and
protein complexes by christopher malus i
am jennifer woods of lab roots and i'll
be moderating today's event before we
begin i'd like to encourage you to
engage with us you can sim you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right or use the
ask a question box on the left
please welcome christopher mallis
all right hello everyone my name is
christopher malus i'm a graduate student
in the david russell research group at
texas a m
university
and today i'm going to talk a bit about
some of the work that we've done with
native mass spectrometry and native ion
mobility mass spectrometry of large
proteins of protein complexes
i'm really trying to study these
proteins in their native
folded as well as intact states for the
protein complexes
so to start a little bit of background
on mass spectrometry so mass
spectrometry really has three primary
components the first one
that we're interested in is ionization
and with ionization the the main
ionization
method that we use in our lab is
electrospray ionization so with
electrospray ionization you have some
electrospray solution
uh
or you have some solution in a spray
needle uh with
in our case a positive potential for
positive ion mode and it's going to form
a taylor cone
towards
our inlet to our mass spectrometer under
vacuum which is generally held at a
negative potential
and this tends to work very well for
positive ion mode as we form droplets
those droplets undergo coulombic
explosions to form smaller droplets and
eventually solvent free gas phase ions
that will enter into the mass
spectrometer
now on the agilent sources
the electric solution is held at ground
and our inlet to the mass spectrometer
is held at a negative potential but that
potential drop across between
the electrospray needle and the inlet to
the mass spectrometer
as long as that forms a negative
potential drop between the two
we can get our ions in
a second component is a mass analyzer
for mass analysis
in our lab that primarily consists of
quadrupoles time of flight mass
analyzers as well as orbit traps
and then
after mass analysis we obviously need
math detection
now some tandem techniques that we can
combine
including mass spectrometry include
tandem mass spectrometry where for our
group
for the agile instruments we use the
agilent 6545 xt qtof mass spectrometer
but we can also
hyphenate mass spectrometry with ion
mobility spectrometry which i'll get in
to a bit later in the talk
uh and for that we've been using the
agilent 6560
iron mobility qtof mass spectrometer
so i talked a bit about electrospray
ionization here
and there's really two types of
electrospray ionization that we use in
our lab the first is going to be direct
infusion
so with direct infusion agilent's
solution to this has been primarily
through the jet spray technology where
you have some
solution being infused
into a nebulizer
we form the droplets at the end of that
nebulizer with the help of a heated
sheath gas and then these ions make a
right turn into the ion transfer
capillary
and undergo further desolvation with
with the heated drying gas
in this method
but in our lab we also use what we refer
to as static nanoelectrospray
and with this rather than flowing at a
constant flow rate we can load an
emitter a glass emitter uh in this case
with some sort of solution um in the low
microliter range of volume uh and then
we we have our custom-made tip holder
that we fabricated in-house as well as
syringe for backing pressure and this
fits neatly into the agilent capillary
holder
which is greatly amenable to the agilent
nano spray source
and once inside the sagittal nanospray
source we have a platinum wire is
inserted into the solution which is
grounded and held in proximity to the
spray shield which is held at the
negative potential to facilitate
formation of the taylor cone and
ionization
now there's pros and cons to both of
these methods so for direct infusion one
of the one of the biggest pros is that
it's very amenable to online hplc
which allows it to have both high
throughput and relatively high
reproducibility
from from sample to sample
that said with direct confusion there's
a very high sample consumption relative
to static nanospray
on the the order of microliters per
minute uh it generally requires a wash
between samples
to avoid contamination and depending on
the type of direct confusion you use
especially with microflow devices these
devices can be very prone to clogging
which can be very difficult or even
impossible to resolve
especially with stainless steel
capillaries that might be used for
direct infusion now static nanospray
we can drop our sample consumption rate
down to microliters per hour
by loading in those the the solution
into those emitters
we can spray over several hours
on a single emitter
and these are often very amenable to
native mass spectrometry because not
only can we still use
buffers and cosolutes that are very
amenable to
mass spectrometry namely
ammonium acetate
but we're also forming smaller droplets
uh through diesel which which are easier
to desolvate
and are generally going to form fewer
adducts
on the the final droplet and the final
ion
um however some some con some negatives
of static nano spray is that it's not
quite high throughput yet
um it still requires a very manual
process of loading the emitter
as well as with sample as well as
loading the emitter into
whatever its holder device is
uh static aspect also necessitates the
use of offline buffer exchange um so we
will typically
dissolve our samples in water and then
undergo a
sample exchange to an ammonium acetate
containing solution
and it requires a much more hands-on
approach
for now although there is work
underway to try to make this a more
automated process
so some of the work that we've done with
static nanospray
is really to look at native protein
complexes
so again we're using our our custom tip
holder
with our solution with with
somewhere between one and five
microliters of sample
and generally with these we get very
good
uh native mass spectro protein complexes
so here's some data on alcohol
dehydrogenase and pyruvate kinase these
are both homotetrameric protein
complexes
of above 100 kilodaltons in molecular
weight
and generally what we see is we see very
good agreement between an experimentally
measured
molecular weight and a theoretical
molecular weight based on the accepted
sequence of these protein complexes
and we can start to tease out some low
molecular or some low relative abundant
species in the mass spectrum for both of
these so for alcohol dehydrogenase we
see our charge state distribution
of the native homo tetrameric complex
centered at 27 plus pyruvate kinase
we're centered at 36 plus
but if we look at
the center
charge state for alcohol dehydrogenase
and expand it we can start to tease out
and really look at some low relative
abundance
uh low molecular weight adducts
uh here we're looking at the again the
four the 27 plus tetramer
and we can do some collisional
activation and
and dissociate that tetramer into a high
charge monomer and generally a low
charge and minus one mir
so in this case we're not looking at the
trimer but the timer is going to exist
with residual low charge
but we see this monomer at 18 plus and
we can start to start to observe
separation in the mass domain
or weight uh non-specific adducts
and based on the charge state
distributor the charge states analyze as
well as the the massive charge spacing
we can start to
pull out uh some of the changes in
molecular weight so we can see that in
our intact tetramer we see an adduct
shift of around 660 daltons
but breaking that up into the monomer we
can start to see that there are several
different adducts
that we're still working to identify
what these are
the different adducts
on each monomer that are going to
complicate the interrogation of that
intact tetramer
we can start to see that there are
several different adducts bound to
alcohol dehydrogenase
we've also looked at some native
membrane protein complexes
again this work is on the the 6545xt
primarily we've looked at the ammonium
transport channel from e coli
also known as amtb
it's an integral membrane protein
complex that exists as a homo trimer
and here we're gonna we're gonna look at
some data for double mutant
um from the ligonowski group at texas a
m
and in general at low collision energy
uh we see a nice distribution of the
intact
trimer ions
centered at 16 plus and if we increase
our collision energy we can start to
increase the population or increase the
the relative abundance of the monomer as
we start to eject out
monomers from start to dissociate
monomers from the intact trimmers
and now if we look close more closely at
the the signal for the trimer
and look at the zero charge mass
spectrum we can start to observe
these low molecular weight adducts
identified as 77 dalton shifts
up to three of them and then
look at the signal for
the ejected monomer we can also see that
we have single 77 dalton shifts
in numeric units
uh and what we've attributed these two
is beta mercaptoethanol at uh or bound
to
uh the intact or one bound to each of
the monomer
as bme was was added to the purification
protocol by its prevent nominated
disulfide formation of this cysteine
mutant
and this is a really good example i
think of being able to identify these
low molecular weight adducts we're
looking at 77 dalton shifts on a protein
complex whose intact weight is somewhere
around 127 kilodaltons
so we've also looked at the grow el
protein chaperone
it's a protein folding chaperone from e
coli
it exists as a homo tetradecamer or 14
mer
made of stacked tetrameric rings so if
we look at the crystal structure they
can say there's nice seven fold symmetry
i'm looking down the barrel
and then nice two-fold symmetry looking
across
intact and it's 14-mercer state it's
around 101 kilograms as an attack
complex with around 550 amino acids per
subunit so it's a it's a very large
protein um yet sub mega dalton
uh and this protein is important because
it assists in protein folding vivo with
a growia sort of lid complex that exists
as a as a seven
heptamer
and in general what the the mag of the
accepted mechanism uh for their
interaction is that you have an unfolded
protein you here uh that's going to bind
into
uh one of the the chambers of groel
either the top or the bottom um we're
going to bind
a groes lid complex as well as some atp
hydrolysis of atp is going to induce
refolding of that unfolded protein to a
native protein and then that native
protein as well as the grow yes lid will
dissociate
shortly thereafter
so some native mass spectra of growell
under low source energy so this is the
the capillary exit voltage of around 200
volts we see very nice arrival or mass
to charge distributions
of the intact 14mm as well as some high
molecular weight contaminant ions
now these native ions are above 10 000 m
over z uh so if we actually zoom in on
this massive charge range we can see
very well resolved uh charge states
um
centered at 74 around 75 plus
uh and with signals going up to around
12 000 l over z for the intact complex
uh the zero charge molecular weight for
this complex is around 801
kilograms which again is in good
agreement with the theoretical molecular
weight of groel
and if we increase the capillary exit
voltage
up to 380 volts we can start to
dissociate out some monomer dimer as
well as trimer
ions
and all of these
ions have very
similar molecular weights for the
subunits
and these molecular weights agree very
well with the theoretical microwave of
groel monomers
which is pretty impressive performance
for this instrument
we can also do cid of native growiel
instead of in the source region as we
showed in the previous slide this time
in the collision cell uh between the
quadrupole
and the time of flight mass analyzer on
the 45 xt
and then generally what we see is as we
increase the collision energy
we start to see a shift towards lower
molecular weight
of
of the intact
14 mer complex
shifting from around 800 and
800 873 down to 800
414
so a loss of about 450 daltons uh prior
to dissociation
and we showed on the previous
slide that we can look at the ejected
subunits
but if we look at
the ions at towards a higher mass to
charge
we can also see signals for the
remaining complex
so in this case we see
signals for the charge drift 13 mer so
we form a monomer
with high charge and a 13 left over with
low
charge we see that these 13 murder
signals
are up to around 22 000 m over z so this
is really taking advantage of the high
mass to charge capabilities of this
instrument
and again like i said before that we see
that shift towards lower mass prior to
dissociation um so from this data as
well as the data shown previously we can
start to put together um these sort of
molecular formulas where we have a 14 r
with a 75 plus charge as the centroid
and this is going to dissociate into a
13 mirror with around 43 plus and a
monomer with around 32 plus
based on the the cid mechanisms here
one thing to note here
is that we still see that low molecular
weight or the the low relative abundance
high molecular weight contaminant at
around 465 kilohms
but with the reduced abundance of all
the ions you start to see
a higher relative abundance of this 28
mer that's around 1.6 mega daltons
and this is about the highest molecular
weight i
observed on this instrument and i think
it bodes well
for some of the
intact virus work as well as antibody
work
to really look at these high molecular
weight species and their native intact
states
so we also in our lab so this is this is
the work done on the
6545xt
but one of the focuses of our group is
also an ion mobility spectrometry
so for those that are a bit less
familiar with that
imobility spectrometry is a very
complementary
separation to math
of charge separation on mass
spectrometers
it fits neatly within the time scales of
lcms where you have hvlc where you have
separations of the orders of seconds to
minutes
and mass spec where you have separation
on the order of microseconds uh and most
mobility experiments are in that that
millisecond range so it fits very neatly
between the duty cycles
and the the time scans of lc and mass
spec
now there are several uh sort of flavors
or variations of vine mobility um and
almost all of the commercial vendors
have really pushed in their own
directions
in these fields um
namely with with drip tube with the
idling system traveling wave on the
senate platforms for waters as well as
trout dying mobility on the on the tim's
systems for brooker
um
now some of the fundamentals of
ability
uh so for especially for drift tube and
for traveling wave item mobility you
have ions
that are pulsed into a region filled
with above
gas under a weak electric field
uh and these ions are generally uh as
well as their charge for the besides
that you got how they interact and
collide with the buffer gas
in this region and the charge is going
to impact
uh how the rack field
in the in the moby device
um and
with the combinations you can start to
measure uh some ion neutral collision
cross sections to be able to compare
within different laboratories within
different instruments within different
mobility devices as well
and some of the fundamental math behind
it is that you have some mobility k is
equal to the velocity of the ion so the
drift velocity of the ions divided by
the electric field where the electric
field is the the experimental parameter
defined by the the delta v or the change
in voltage
across the mobility device as well as
the length of that mobility device
and if we rearrange these equations a
little bit we get that the inverse
mobility is equal to the drift time
times the change in voltage across the
drift tube divided by the length of that
drift tube squared
and if we take it one step further we
can combine this with with what's
referred to as a mason shop equation to
calculate ion neutral collision cross
sections where you have
that the ccs as the omega term
uh is dependent on the charge z of the
ions the number density of the drift gas
and as well as the reduced mass mu
between the ion and the drift gas the
temperature and then that inverse
mobility term that was defined
previously
and this is this is
one of the the fundamentals of drift
tube
uh ion mobility is that you're able to
calculate these from first principles
and almo and all of the
other drift tube or all the other
mobility devices the collision cross
sections you get out of those are all
calibrated
or experimentally determined
against those determined by
uniform field drift tube devices
and now we can take these collision
cross sections that we've determined
experimentally again calculate them
based on your experimental results and
compare them between different devices
and we can also compare them um
to those calculated from x-ray or nmr
structures available in the pdb on the
pdb
and with recent advances in
cryo-electron microscopy we've also
compared some of these values to
those structures as well although i
won't be talking about that in my talk
today
so some of the work that we've done
recently
looking at ion mobility mass spec of
native alcohol dehydrogenase
on the agilent 6560
we're on the left-hand side we have our
iron source
in this case using again our our static
spray
custom tip holder
where the ions are then introduced into
a high pressure ion funnel followed by a
trapping funnel which will trap and
release ions into the drift tube for
iron mobility separation and then they
will be refocused from that separation
through the rear ion funnel and then
eventually guide it into the
time-of-flight mass analyzer
so if we look at mobility spectra of
native alcohol dehydrogenase we can look
at our data
first starting with the
the mass spectrum and from the mass
spectrum we can start to identify
charge state distributions in this case
for the monomer dimer and tetramer ions
with charged distribution centered at 11
17 and 24 plus respectively
but we can also look at this data in a
two-dimensional plot
of
drift time versus
mass to charge
and from these we can start to identify
our charge date distributions along
these mobility trend lines
where we can start to see our monomer
dimer and tetramer ions like we saw in
our mass spectrum but we can also start
to tease out some other complexes namely
here that the pentamer
of adh centered at 28 plus as well as
some other
complex of around 55 kilometers that
we're still working to identify what
that complex might be
because it isn't a simple
transformation of
what we would expect to see from the
native tetramer
we've also looked at iron mobility mass
spec of c reactive protein
which is a pentameric protein complex of
around 115 kilograms
and our native spectra from ammonium
acetate solutions
we see a nice distribution of our intact
petrentimer
as well as some dimers of those
pentomers seen as decamer signals
and in general the subunit molecular
weights agree really well with a
theoretical molecular weight of the
subunit of around 23 047 daltons
and we can start to see in the mobility
in the mobility domain that we actually
have two conformers
we have this sort of compact conformer
highlighted in green
or in in blue rather and an extended
copper are highlighted in red
and we can also look at charge-reduced
c-reactive proteins so we can charge
reduce it by adding in a small amount of
triethyl ammonium acetate tea a is a
charge-reducing reagent
and this this shifts the charge state
down from a center of 23 to a center of
17 in our charge state distribution
and again has really good agreement
between
the theoretical molecular weight of the
subunits and the experimentally
um
calculated subunit molecular weights uh
but again we see this distribution of
these two conformers uh and if we
compare these conformers
along their collision cross-section axis
we can start to look at the relative
abundance of the compact conformer
relative to the extended conformer
both in our native c reactive protein
mobility spectra as well as our charge
reduced crp spectra where we can see
that at low charge
we start to populate that low that low
arrival time low collision cross section
or rather small collision cross section
signal so
we've looked at
so far
native collision cross sections or
native
ion mobility mass spec data where we try
to keep the internal energy of the ions
as low as we possibly can through the
sampling
but one thing we can do is we can we can
take this a step further and do what we
refer to as collision induced unfolding
so the collision induced unfolding we
can study the effects of collisional
activation on protein structure
and protein complex structure prior to
dissociation
we can do this by progressively
collisionally activating these
biomolecular ions to unfold them prior
to the fragmentation or dissociation
so in general how this looks is you have
some sort of a compact drift time or
compact collision cross-section profile
and as you increase the collision
voltage you start to unfold the protein
ions in the gas phase as you unfold them
their size gets larger as their charge
stays largely stays the same
and this is going to lead to a shift in
the arrival time or the drift time of
these ions as a function of collision
voltage
so what we can do is we can plot the
arrival time distribution or the drift
times as a functional collision of
collision voltage um
into a nice 2d plot
where
we can convert
or we can we can rather show these sort
of waterfall type plots as a nice plot
of drift time or collision cross action
as a function of collision voltage to
look at these transitions as a function
of collision energy
now to do collision induced unfolding on
any instrument or any unmobility mass
spectrometry instrument
requires an activation step prior to
mobility separation
so
on
the agilent 6560 there's there's a
collision cell
in the instrument but it's located post
mobility so you would be unable to do
collision juice unfolding by just
changing the voltage applied to the
collision cell
so in this case
we've partnered with with agilent
and especially rouen krilligama
in santa clara to develop
this activation cell uh at the front of
the high pressure ion funnel
where there's a potential drop between
the exit of the ion transfer capillary
capillary as well as capillary exit lens
to accelerate ions into this region
activate them
prior to their transmission into the
drift tube
and then we can look at the activation
of designs the arrival time or drift
time distributions as a function of the
the insource collision energy
so some of the early work
that
some of the preliminary work that i've
done recently
on this
is namely to look at collision-reducing
folding of grow es so gross is that that
ethameric
lid complex that interacts with groel
and in general under low source
collision energies we see a nice
distribution
of
that hepatomeric protein complex
centered at a charge state of around 20
plus
and as we start to increase that source
collision energy we start to not only
dissociate out and start to form signals
for an ejected monomeric complex as we
reduce the relative abundance of the
intact hepatomeric complexes
but we also start to unfold these
complexes
so we can see that as we increase the
collision voltage at a certain point the
protein complex will undergo an
unfolding step
which is observed pretty clearly in the
21 plus
2d ciu fingerprint uh where we start to
see unfolding to the secondary complex
at around 65 milliseconds
however one thing to note and one thing
to that we need to be paying attention
to here is that because we might be
dissociating this complex in this case
we see signal that's isobaric with the
21 plus seven mer complex
of the three plus monomer that's formed
via dissociation
so this is something to be sort of
considerate about in these experiments
so we've also looked at collision
induced unfolding of bovine serum
albumin using some of the the newer
technology that's been developed
and in general at low collision energies
we see
the monomeric bsa complex centered at
around 16 plus using our device as well
as some low relative abundance dimer
signal
and as we collisionally activate these
ions
we can start to unfold them and
especially on the 15 plus we can start
to see these different features
uh populate as we start to to unfold the
bsa monomers
into their unfolded non-native states in
the gas phase
so in summary
um we've worked on in in our lab and and
with the projects i've been working on
we've worked on development of native
mass spec and ims capabilities for large
proteins and protein complexes
namely using the the high mass modes
available on the 45 xt as well as the
6560
imqtoff platforms
we work through integration of static
nano electrospray emitters with the
agilent nano spray source design so we
can limit our sample consumption as well
as really push native mass spectrometry
on these different instruments
and then we're currently trying to
progress towards collision-induced
unfolding of large protein complexes
um and really evaluating some of some of
the newer technology for ciu
on especially the the 6560 time ketov
platform
and with that i'd like to make my
acknowledgements uh so first and
foremost to texas a m and my principal
investigator um and boss dr david
russell uh for really helping to push
this project along and facilitate the
discussion between
our research group and agilent
um and and push really the next steps of
this project which look really promising
i'd also like to thank jacob mccabe in
our group for helping
with the the
creation and and really manufacturing of
the static spray tip holders um dr sheen
shang who's now at p now back at pnnl
for helping
uh
and collection of that data especially
the amtb spectra um
and also her work on on the ciu
collaboration with agilent and with ruan
um i'd like to thank the art lagowski's
group for their donation of the amtb
samples and hayes rise group at
a m for their donation of the growie l
and grow es complexes
from agilent technologies there's a lot
of people to thank
including she who helped us get the 45
xt work started and gave us an early
visit
for that work noah goldberg and ken
newton have been really helpful with
getting myself to understand the design
of the source region especially on the
45 xt
uh ruan's been very helpful and has been
working really hard on the design and
implementation of the clinton the
collision induced unfolding devices
used in the 6560 uh april holcomb for
her help with the installation of that
device uh john sawson and john falstad
have both been really really helpful and
i'd like to thank them for
getting this project sort of off the
ground
um
and facilitating the the meetings
amongst everyone as well as lauren for
her for helping to organize
the logistics for the symposium uh then
lastly i'd like to thank the nih for
funding
we have a pretty
pretty good
p-41 grant and a resource in native mass
spec guided structural biology it's
provided a lot of funding a lot of
collaboration with with the members of
that of that grant
for discussing and trading ideas uh for
these different projects
and with that thank you thank you for
listening to my talk if you'd like to
reach out to me uh to either ask
questions you didn't think of here
or
if you would like a copy of the paper
that's been recently published on the
work from the 45 xt that i showed in the
first half of my talk feel free to reach
out
my email is on the screen there
and with that thank
you thank you christopher for your
informative presentation we've received
some great questions already our first
question is
how long is the grow el cid data being
averaged for to produce the spectra
shown
so each of the the cid scans here
we're probably somewhere on the order of
30 seconds to two minutes
with the the agilent software it
actually makes it pretty easy to do
sort of sweeping ciu runs where you can
sweeping cid runs where you can assign a
certain collision voltage or
fragment or voltage
for that matter
and then acquire each of those for you
know a minute and then swap between the
two so all of your data is collected in
a single data file
uh but yeah those are probably somewhere
on the order of a minute or two
per scan
and then for the ciu data at each
collision voltage uh we're acquiring on
the order of less than 30 seconds and
and some of the more recent work is
really to try to push that
push that number down so we can get more
scans and in fewer amount of time
or in less amount of time
for those experiments
great thank you christopher our next
question
do you know whether your group and
agilent will be releasing some sort of
instrument insert for ion activation for
ciu experiments
yeah so
we're currently working on on evaluating
a newer generation a newer design of
that that ciu
sort of source modification
um i believe agilent's plan is to is to
develop that and launch that as part of
the 6560 platform or the next generation
of the imq top platform
but in terms of of when that might be
happening i'm not sure but i do believe
that that is that is a plan in the
future
okay great thank you so much christopher
as a reminder to our audience questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed via the email address
you provided at the time of registration
thanks again to our speaker christopher
and to everyone who participated in this
presentation we hope you enjoy the rest
of the event
oh well we may have another may have
another guest here
sure
there was a question that came up
regarding status on the ciu and uh
chris is absolutely right the intent for
agilent is to actually
launch that capability probably as we
get into uh part of next year sometime
in 2021 i would expect to see that
capability coming available um and uh
chris and dave russell and his team have
been doing a great job of helping us as
also we've been working with brandon
rutlow also up at michigan on the same
capability so both labs have been
terrific collaborators and helping us
with this biu and and developing that
and then
that static nano spray also looks very
exciting
thank you so much and john do you want
to introduce yourself so the audience
knows who who you are
sure
john slawson i'm part of the america's
field operation uh director of strategic
initiatives for the mass spec team and
uh thanks again chris for a great talk
appreciate you guys doing that and the
work you've been doing
thanks john thanks for all the help
well thank you so much christopher and
thank you john as well for coming in um
if we don't have any more questions then
i would like to just reiterate that any
questions we didn't have time for today
or those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
and thank you again both to christopher
and to john and all who participated in
this presentation and we hope you enjoy
the rest of the event